that's why I got a debate club for you
since Chappell didn't sound too
interested in the barbecue collab agree
but y'all rather have Chappelle's thick
boring nation BB q or Chin's hot spicy
Korean BB q let me know what you think
gang gang but [ __ ] yeah come on
so basically he's asking if it's
barbecue or a Korean barbecue listen man
I know where you're at on this game
there is nothing better than American
barbecue you go down the truth of July
every day
yeah there's nothing better than a nice
[ __ ] full rack of ribs or some
brisket some nice corn bread it's all in
the sauce bro it's all on the sauce you
got a good sweet barbecue sauce a little
Hickory so without Carolina yet auric
and making just here's the other thing
now you got now yeah yeah do you like it
wet you like to get wet dog or do you
like a dry rub you gotta think about
what you're doing Chappelle it's got a
lot of [ __ ] work to do dude
gotta lay some [ __ ] [ __ ] wonderful
you bought one gold chain actually I
didn't buy this my girlfriend uh
actually took it from her Nicki Minaj
little Kim little Kim believes in
pigeons dude I'm telling you man yeah
you got to get something going broker
you're wasting time and whatever you
know what we're doing wasting ideas got
a great business plan that someone right
now is probably putting [ __ ] together
I'm 60 now I'm gonna walk out here and
it's [ __ ] smoking Lacey's barbecue
and you're like oh what the [ __ ]
first of all y'all don't know what I'm
doing at home yeah you told us you
hadn't been doing this from the giant
yeah you're right sir my bad double
you're doing good man let's see with
this girl wait you didn't answer it's a
little of both South American barbecue
right oh yeah barbecue yeah I go
American Bar we have a crew in barbecue
just because I think if I go to Korea or
I go to a Korean place that I want
Korean barbecue you know but on the
holiday I think I want American barbecue
I want American barbecue 24/7 70
a week yeah it's good Oh bro I'll take
that in um dude brothers barbecue in
Denver Colorado needs to English
brothers who went around all Texas and
Oklahoma was like oh these are good
ideas store all their [ __ ] come out
white people do with black people
culture store Native American culture
dude don't all these black people you
know all the barbecue ideas and create
their best called brothers barbecue why
people still white culture to the lot
going to the library you've seen a black
guy at the library I go to the library
there you got a fair point
Brit library's a very British system I
think mmm might be Greek actually shot
two brothers BBQ though is it good Wow
the best what do you think I would
usually say Korean barbecue but if you
have cornbread I'm always gonna go for
American barbecue mmm I will age cobbler
I will know that is cornbread in general
I'm going nuts man I'm riled up because
Chappelle we need to get your [ __ ]
business started cuz the other thing
he's not gonna do it all those people on
a chain all those people are so those
people eat their barbecue they want to
wash it down with a nice dessert so
you're gonna have to have peach cobbler
you have to have a banana custard maybe
it's not have an entree yet Brendan yeah
right he doesn't have a business model
he doesn't even have a frickin JPEG or
anything yeah logo dude yeah he doesn't
even want to do it I don't think we
thought maybe we should do our own huh
well we could eat a food truck and makes
your pouch FL drive it yeah do you have
a commercial driver's license CDL Wow
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]